[Musik]
polizisten die auf township bewohner
einprügeln soldaten die ihre macht
missbrauchen
militär und polizei sollen die
ausgangssperre in südafrika durchsetzen
immer wieder kommt es zu machtmissbrauch
demütigungen und gewalt
es gibt tote und verletzte wir sind in
vossloh russ einem vorort von
johannesburg
hier lebt kombiklasse amos am 29 märz
kam polizisten auf das grundstück der
familie
einer von ihnen schoss auf ihren cousin
sibusiso er starb kurz darauf
mein cousin stand hier
ich zog ihn zurück denn ich stand hinter
ihm und ich schloss dabei das gitter als
ich das gitter schloss stand mein co za
hier und der polizist dort wo sie jetzt
stehen
ich stand an der seite als der polizist
merkte dass er das gitter nicht auf
krieg schoss er auf ihn durch das gitter
auch ihre tochter und drei weitere
kinder der familie wurden durch splitter
verletzt
warum der polizist auf das grundstück
kam ist unklar
tomica jesus sagt ihr cousin unbewaffnet
sie versteht nicht warum der polizist
geschossen hat die ganze zeit über hätte
er sich umdrehen und aufhören können
nicht schießen müssen
er hätte am tor bleiben können es war zu
er hat sich entschieden es zu öffnen und
reinzukommen
er hätte am gitter stoppen können als
ich es geschlossen hatte
doch er hat sich entschieden abzudrücken
die 33-jährige hofft jetzt auf
gerechtigkeit vor gericht
wir sind unterwegs sind alexandra einem
township von johannesburg
militär und polizei patrouillieren
sie sollen eine der strengsten
ausgangssperren der welt durchsetzen
in südafrika darf das haus nur für
lebensnotwendiges verlassen werden
doch in den armen vierteln hält sich
kaum jemand daran die hygienischen
bedingungen sind katastrophal toiletten
und fließendes wasser gibt es oft nur
auf der straße meinte moniz draußen und
zu waschen
das virus macht ihr angst wir haben
angst denn unser leben hier ist sehr
schwierig wie sie sehen teilen wir uns
eine wasserstelle und die toiletten
haben nicht einmal einen abfluss ich
habe kinder die zur schule gehen das ist
hart wir leben in einem einzigen raum
ich meine beiden kinder und mein mann
masken und desinfektionsmittel haben die
wenigsten
die regierung befürchtet dass sich das
virus hier besonders schnell ausbreiten
könnte die bislang durchgeführten tests
scheinen das zu bestätigen
das township ist einer der korona
hotspots im land soldaten und polizisten
sollen dafür sorgen dass die menschen in
ihren häusern bleiben um die ausbreitung
einzudämmen
immer wenn sie hier vorbeikommen sagen
sie uns dass wir zu unserem eigenen
schutz gegen das virus reingehen sollen
und dass wir die kinder schützen müssen
aber wir können nicht einfach drin
bleiben und ich muss wäsche waschen zu
viele menschen leben hier auf engstem
raum bis zu zehn personen in einem haus
einer wellblechhütte das ist auf dauer
nicht auszuhalten erzählen sie uns wir
haben keinen ort wo wir sein können
unsere häuser sind so klein du kannst
kaum atmen drei stunden da drin ist wie
ein gefängnis lohnt
steven quasi ist draußen um seiner frau
ein wenig privatsphäre zu geben
für mich ist kein platz im haus wenn wir
kochen oder uns waschen müssen wir
einander raum geben ich bin draußen weil
meine frau sich wäscht eine
ausgangssperre ist unter diesen
bedingungen quasi unmöglich soldaten und
polizisten versuchen durchzusetzen was
ich hier gar nicht durchsetzen lässt
ob aus überforderung oder frust immer
wieder kommt es zu machtmissbrauch und
gewalt
sie zwingen menschen über den boden zu
räumen
letzte woche musste einer direkt hier
von einer seite zur anderen und
zurückrollen einfach nur so manche
packen dich und schlagen deinen käufern
die wand es gibt zahlreiche aufnahmen
die sowas dokumentieren diese männer
müssen durch abwasser rollen es ist
demütigung
unterwegs sehen wir etwas ähnliches
ein verkehrspolizist lässt junge männer
wie frösche hüpfen und liegestütze
machen als wir mit der kamera aussteigen
fahren sie wenn die soldaten im auto
verbergen ihre gesichter
wir bekommen die gelegenheit eine
patrouille zu begleiten
polizei und militär überprüfen in
vosslohs händler und geschäfte als die
soldaten kommen versucht ein mann den
laden schnell zu schließen und macht
sich damit verdächtig machen sie auch
warum schließen sie die beamten
durchsuchen den laden ihr verdacht
bestätigt sich schnell
sie finden diverse waren die nicht
verkauft werden dürfen erlaubt es
derzeit nur der verkauf von
lebensmitteln
doch die eigentümerin verkauft auch
zigaretten und andere haushaltswaren
sie wird festgenommen die verbotenen
waren beschlagnahmt
ein paar meter weiter erwischt es diesen
stand die frauen haben zwar eine
genehmigung allerdings nicht für diese
uhrzeit
außerdem haben sie auf einem grill essen
zubereitet um es zu verkaufen auch das
ist verboten
sie müssen zusammen packen die soldaten
seien sehr höflich gewesen erzählt uns
eine der händlerinnen sie haben uns gut
behandelt sie haben uns gesagt dass wir
uns an die regeln halten und rechtzeitig
einpacken sollen sie haben uns nicht
schikaniert während wir drehen erleben
wir keine situationen der die
sicherheitskräfte gewalt anwenden oder
ihre macht missbrauchen
vor laufender kamera behandeln polizei
und militär die menschen sowie der
präsident es gefordert hat mit respekt
doch es gibt zahlreiche fälle in denen
exzessiv gewalt angewendet wurde
diverse handy videos zeigen wie
polizisten und soldaten auf anscheinend
unbewaffnete township bewohner
einprügeln oder treten
es gibt sogar tote die behörden
ermitteln in mehreren fällen zurück in
alexandra wir treffen langsam unter die
30 jährige erzählt uns was an karfreitag
geschah sie war mit ihrer familie zu
hause als plötzlich soldaten kommen
ihr schwager will das tor schließen und
macht sich aus sicht der soldaten damit
offenbar verdächtig er versuchte das tor
zu schließen also fragten die soldaten
warum schließt du das tor
er sagte dass er gehört hat dass
soldaten kommen und dass er deshalb das
tor schließt sie kamen mit ihm rein
erst hätten die soldaten die räume
durchsucht sagt sie dann sei es zum
streit gekommen es ging um bier erzählt
simon cho in südafrika ist der verkauf
von alkohol derzeit verboten auf der
straße darf nicht getrunken werden
zu hause aber schon sie fingen an nach
bier zu suchen
als sie den kühlschrank öffneten fanden
sie nur ein bier
das nahmen sie dann mit nach draußen sie
gingen auf die straße mein schwager
fragte sie warum nehmt ihr das bier aus
dem kühlschrank als beweis mit auf die
straße
ihr habt uns nicht auf der straße
trinkend vorgefunden
wir waren im haus da fingen sie an sie
zu schlagen
nom so mancher musste alles mit ansehen
sie erzählt dass die soldaten ihren
schwager und ihren mann collins brutal
verprügelten er starb wenige stunden
später
er hat sich übergeben aber nicht statt
ich habe ihn sauber gemacht dann schlief
er ich dachte er müsse sich nur ausruhen
weil er so oft geschlagen wurde
aber mein mann ist nicht wieder
aufgewacht
auch sie wurde geschlagen sagt thomsa
monza und zeigt uns ihre verletzungen
zeugen die das geschehen filmten wurden
von den soldaten mitgenommen eine von
ihnen spricht mit uns sie möchte
unerkannt bleiben
sie haben uns oft geschlagen dann haben
sie uns aus ihrem fahrzeug geworfen
nachdem sie alles auf unseren handys
gelöscht hatten
[Musik]
monsanto will die täter verklagen
in dem fall ermitteln mehrere behörden
hier gibt es solche eskalation von
gewalt nicht
wir sind unterwegs in reichen vierteln
von johannesburg polizei sieht man kaum
wer hier lebt dem fällt es leicht sich
an die ausgangssperre zu halten
jetzt zu krone zeiten wird die tiefe
spaltung des landes noch sichtbarer not
an bundes behle ist im finanzwesen tätig
jetzt arbeitet sie von zu hause aus
putzen oder waschen muss sie nicht ihre
haushaltshilfe lebt bei ihr auf dem
grundstück und kann somit weiter
arbeiten
die größte veränderung ist der
unterricht zu hause
ich bin alleinerziehende mutter und ich
arbeite während ich versuche meinen job
von zu hause aus zu machen muss ich
zusätzlich meine siebenjährige tochter
unterrichten und die lehrer verlangen
die 46 jährige weiß um ihre
privilegierte stellung und um die not
anderer hilfskräfte wie ihr gärtner der
einmal in der woche kommt sind durch die
ausgangssperre arbeitslos geworden notar
bundes behle bezahlt sie trotzdem weiter
ich musste sie bitten zu hause zu
bleiben aber natürlich haben sie
finanzielle verpflichtungen
deshalb ist es wichtig sie weiter zu
bezahlen und ich bleibe in kontakt mit
ihnen und frage sie wie es ihnen geht
mutter runde behle hofft dass möglichst
viele so handeln
doch nicht jeder kann sich das leisten
diejenigen die durch den lockdown das
eigene einkommen verlieren schicken ihre
mitarbeiter oft ohne geld nach hause
das verstärkt die not in der ärmeren
bevölkerung zb in soweto
hier wächst der hunger immer mehr
menschen sind auf lebensmittelpakete
angewiesen von dies vacuum hat glück sie
hat ein paket bekommen
ich habe fisch in dosen bekommen
bohnen saft cerealien maismehl seife und
milch ich bin dankbar
das wird nicht lange reichen aber es
hilft vor der ausgangssperre hat ihr
mann die familie mit gelegenheitsjobs
ernährt jetzt bleibt ihnen nur noch das
kindergeld weniger als 40 euro im monat
für vier personen sie überleben gerade
so es geht ihnen wie millionen anderen
ab mai sollen die strengen auflagen ein
wenig gelockert werden den ärmsten hilft
das kaum
die ausgangssperre trifft sie am
härtesten und macht die ungleichheit in
südafrika noch größer